Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new Iron Man Marvel
phase 4 video there's been a lot of
Iron Man Robert Downey jr. news lately
since Marvel's fixing a lot of his plans
behind the scenes to adjust for delays
because of the virus but now it seems
like we have some more details about how
Marvel is planning on using the Iron Man
character going forward and Marvel phase
4 in the movies and the New Avengers
Disney Plus series if you're new to my
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos we're doing an Amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave all your
theories about Iron Man
during Marvel phase 4 so we'll just
break this down top five style starting
with number five the confirmed stuff
that we know about right now
the Iron Man scenes from the Marvel what
if trailer that we got just a little
while ago surprisingly for a dead man
there is a ton of Iron Man going on
during Marvel phase 4 in all this
footage but here's the thing even though
there's a ton of Iron Man footage
featured during all this and a bunch of
different Iron Man suits we'll talk
about that in a second because there's
actually a couple cool Easter eggs that
slip through the cracks that I did not
see anyone talking about last year but
noticed that Robert Downey jr. picture
was not featured in the Marvel comic con
panel when they were showing off the
footage when they released the Marvel
what-if trailer they showed off this one
sheet with a bunch of the MCU actors but
I think that these are just meant to be
the actors that had already signed new
contracts as of Comic Con last summer in
d23 they'll be one what if episode 4
every single Marvel movie according to
Kevin Feige so far that's 23 confirmed
episodes total not including Black Widow
who knows when we're going to see that
movie
but what if season 1 isn't going to
premiere till 2021 and they're only
going to do ten episodes per season so
they're just going to break up the MCU
movies season two season there are three
Iron Man movies in a ton of other Iron
Man appearances in the core Avengers
movies as well as the spider-man movies
it will be weird to not do any Iron Man
what-if episodes so of course they got
to get Robert Downey jr. to come back
for that
remember when Spiderman was briefly out
of the MCU around d23 when they were
dropping this trailer and everyone's
like what are they going to do for the
spider-man what-if episodes is Tom
Holland not going to be the spider-man if
all the other MCU actors are going to be
playing their characters on what if well
they answered that question when
Spiderman came back to the MCU and they
signed that new sharing deal
so they got him to come back it sounds
like they're still trying to sign robert
downey jr to a new deal remember
he is expensive so they're probably
trying to talk him down on price but
when they dropped the what-if trailer
because so many people were focusing on
the Captain America footage in the
Marvel Zombies footage everyone just
getting really hyped up about it
no one was actually talking about this
brand-new Iron Man armor that doesn't
look like anything we've seen before and
looks like a modern design something
from around Avengers infinity war in
Avengers end game so what sounds like
it's just an example of the what-if
episodes that they've been pitching to
Robert Downey jr. in his agents trying
to get him to come back based on the
look of the armor I also have some
theories about when this would happen in
the timeline and what kind of adventure
that would be for him most of the other
Iron Man footage in the what-if trailer
actually focused on the Steve Rogers
version of Iron Man that's for the
Captain America First Avenger
what if episode where Peggy Carter
becomes Captain Britain taking the Super
Soldier Serum and Steve Rogers gets an
Iron Man suit made by Howard Stark with
the design language of World War 2 so
he's basically flying around in a giant
tank so he's actually a little bit more
like war machine than he is like Iron
Man so they're bearing the lead a little
bit on Chris Evans coming back to do his
what-if episodes too just like Robert
Downey jr. but I think they're still
trying to figure out what a lot of those
episodes are going to be number 4
talking about the big MCU movies
obviously most of the Marvel phase 4
movies with the very few exceptions will
take place after Avengers end game when
Iron Man is still dead Marvel's already
said he's not coming back to life Robert
Downey jr. said he's not going to rush to
jump back into the movies so most of the
Marvel phase 4 movies are going to use
him the same way that they used him
during spider-man far from home another
really good example is also using a lot
of the Iron Man mythology that they set
up in those films like Iron Man 3 with
the Mandarin for shang-chi and the
legend of the ten rings lot of Iron Man
Easter eggs happening in that movie
there's a lot that we don't know about
Spider Man 3 but Spider Man still has
the orbital weapons platform technology
in Tony Stark's glasses so wire man is
still a big part of their storytelling
in what's going on without him actually
walking on screen number 3 this is the
news that a lot of you have been asking
me about recently there have been
several reports from blogs all over the
place for the last couple of months
that Robert Downey jr. is in early talks
to return in an Iron Man Marvel phase
4series on Disney Plus not coming
back from the dead because it be set
during present day coming back to do
voiceover work just like he do for work
for the what-if episodes if he's already
in talks to do the what-if episodes it's
not a big stretch to say Marvel would
try to get him to do voiceover work in
other episodes too but the Iron Man
series that he's supposedly in talks for
is an Iron Heart series there were a lot
of you asking about this about comic-con
last year too and they were announcing
all the Marvel phase 4 series at the
time I hadn't seen any of the larger
news sites or official reports talking
about Robert Downey jr. wanting to do an
Iron Heart series or what that would
even look like who would be that Iron
Heart character but a little while after
that Robert Downey jr. was at an awards
gala honoring Jon Favreau giving this
big intro speech in the person that
introduced Robert Downey jr. on stage
was the writer of the iron heart comic
book and she said he publicly talked
about wanting iron heart in the MCU
during that big speech a couple other
big news sites verified that so it
sounds like Robert Downey jr. does like
the idea of an Iron Heart series so it
makes sense that Marvel would try to
talk him into coming back to do
voiceover work for that I don't know
about Pepper Potts coming back there
been reports that he wants her to come
back to but I think that's just a rumor
right now in Gwyneth Paltrow also kind
of retired from the Marvel movies last
year but then after everybody freaked
out they're like wait a minute no more
Pepper Potts
ever she said she'd always come back to
be Pepper Potts for Tony Stark
if Robert Downey jr. wanted her to come
back but number two Robert Downey jr.
talking publicly about the Iron Heart
series he himself doesn't read a lot of
comic books so it sounds like just a lot
of people at Marvel pitched him the idea
in the writer of the comic book tried to
pitch him on the idea if they do wind up
casting that character it probably
someone like storm read someone who's
young enough that she would be of a
similar age to the Young Avengers
characters they've already got inside
the MCU in the new ones that we're going to
meet during the Marvel phase 4 series
like the Kate Bishop Hawkeye character
if you've seen a lot of the other a
Marvel phase for Disney Plus videos that
I've done for the big series like Wanda
vision for the Loki series and the other
stuff that's going on you probably
notice the Marvel has already confirmed
a number of characters that were member
of the comic-book Young Avengers at one
point or another a couple years ago
Kevin Feige said that they were
considering a Young Avengers project
that was before they had announced the
Disney Plus was a thing before they
launched it so no idea whether that
would be a movie or if it'd be a Disney
Plus series I would love to see a
six-episode Young Avengers Disney Plus
series but because of all the delays
with the virus and because of all the
stuff they've already announced we
probably wouldn't be able to see that
for at least a couple years there was an
iron heart script that wound up on the
Hollywood blacklist website last year
but it's unclear if Marvel optioned that
or if they just commissioned someone
else to develop the project but it does
sound like there really is an iron heart
project in some phase of development at
Marvel if it winds up happening you guys
can let me know in the comments who
would you want to play that iron heart
character speaking of which number one
what about Iron Man's daughter Morgan
Stark what about the iron lad character
he's a founding member of the Young
Avengers and he's the younger form of
King the Conqueror this is basically
King as a little kid I've already done a
couple videos about Kang the Conqueror
in the Marvel Loki's series on Disney
plus they're supposed to be doing a lot
more time-travel villains and he's
obviously a big slam dunk for the MCU
he's also a really big Young Avengers
villain so it's obviously just more
Young Avengers stuff in the background
of the MCU right now hopefully that
winds up seeing the light of day the
actors who played teenage Morgan Stark
though you all remember is Catherine
Lankford from 13 reasons why they shot a
big scene of her meeting iron man in the
soul world of the soul stone after he
snapped his Nano Infinity Gauntlet I
posted that scene to my channel last
year so I'll link it at the end of this
she said she's always been a big fan of
the Marvel movies and she jumped at a
chance to do this so it sounds like she
does want to come back but because she's
supposed to be 10 to 15 years older than
this young version of Morgan Stark the
only real way to bring her back would be
in a time travel story like a young
Avengers story so maybe that'll happen
maybe not I'm not going to hold my breath
on that remember ty simpkins who played
Harley keener in Iron Man 3 he was the
older looking kid in the background of
Iron Man's funeral at the end of
Avengers endgame he said he would love
to play iron lad in the MCU
but everyone let me know in the comments
what do you think about Robert Downey
jr. coming back to do voiceover work for
his what if Iron Man episodes and what
do you think about the idea of him
coming
back to do some voiceover for an iron
heart series at some point just looking
at the schedule they probably wouldn't
be able to premiere a project like that
at least until 2022 or 2023 at the
earliest
if Marvel makes any other big
announcements about how their plans for
the movies and the Disney Plus series
have changed because of the virus I'll
totally do an update video but leave all
your requests in the comments below
congratulations mark Capobianco you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
Marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so we can get
your contact details
everyone click here for that Avengers
endgame deleted scene of Iron Man
meeting his daughter in the soul world
and click here for my brand-new Morbius
spider-man video thank you so much for
watching everyone stays safe.
I'll see you guys tonight!